one minute from kickoff for the agad
mater's cake defy christmas arena
biggest bold event
after a hiccup to start
some technical difficulties it's now
been sorted out
the beefy list
carlson artemy of narditzky bortnick
robson nakamura
farouza jagalco
i don't know doesn't have it in the
profile
and i'm not recalling the name here for
chess today
there will be some more entering for
that initial start there was over four
seventeen thousand
it's getting back up there approaching
10 000.
under 17 to go
i'll be tracking
the five-time champ himself
dr championstein
one magnus carlson they are playing for
top prize one bitcoin
that's the payout top three get some
money
here we go
are things gonna go smooth this time
around we're gonna find out we do have a
pairing game one
a big pairing right here
carlson versus convlad no berserks
i said it before the event i'm gonna
stick to it i think
the winner of this will have to
make use of the berserk i'm thinking
more than 50 percent of the time you may
have to berserk
in order to get more games in there
especially after a loss too i think
that's an important strategy
all right so what's happening here
this guy right here needs some help
is there going to be some attack against
the king
this knight on e4
soon maybe rook to d8 rook d8
discourages knight e4 there could there
could be some trick
not the most comfortable square but you
know we're we're getting ready for a
night move now knight f4 is that
irritating
knight f4 into d3
this is a sensitive point
for right now this bish this uh knight
is under control
the queen is defended by the bishop
otherwise there might be some tricks
here
and after a capture a check
okay so the bishop is
anticipating that night move bishop is
controlling the knight
no no peace jump to g5 queen now on this
better looking square prepare to give up
the bishops okay two knights
on the king's
side there might be some accident
happening here not quite potentially
looking for a battery
getting into this square now there was a
problem on f3 light square bishop was a
great piece now the knight looking to
neutralize this guy
only imbalance here is with regard to
the queen side structure big time edge
for white
knight vs bishop position the wheels are
in motion on the queen side the queen is
super duper active
hitting a7
not a great way to defend that okay that
this guy gets rolling the queen is also
in a good spot to prevent any perpetuals
i wondered about why not why not this
check and then maybe c5
wouldn't that have been a
a better way
queen is good here securing a3 time to
get running with the pawn we got a live
pawn it's a passer
and can the knight get here
one two
you have to stop night there the knights
dancing you don't have to worry about
this this pawn bolts and next up this
and then that he knows it's coming he
resigns convlide goes down
look at this guy
yeah okay sure
three three five
that's one to keep an eye on there we go
carlson in this next game
a lower a lower opponent here
a berserk game
one minute to a minute 49
ryorio one is the opponent
all right we're getting we have what is
this the uh mardel plata
play on the king side
for black play on the queen side for
white
g4 break is in there
queen has entered hitting b7 now
takes the knight
probably won't exchange queens first
otherwise you might get killed very soon
at this point you don't really care so
much about dropping d6
the knight on h4 can be really really
good
probably a best square for a knight in
this structure
and
yep preparing knight h4 probably have to
give up the exchange soon
34 seconds
for carlson
where's the queen go you could take here
and then take here
light squares are broken
[Music]
hitting the queen again this guy's
putting up some resistance here for sure
but this should they should be winning
the the black queen is
a very hungry piece
i expect e4 to collapse soon
think tank for team white
queen takes bishop no
kicking the queen off of this post right
here oh yeah preventing the doubling
first
yeah and white can't get here white
isn't able to converge on the bishop
under 30 now for each
oh that night is pinned
toast
keep your opponent in a pin
multiple pins here
okay
it's obviously going to take this one 15
seconds is plenty
all right we're gonna see the next
pairing
six minutes into this event
gotta win fast and get another pairing
no stalemates to worry about with this
guy around okay pairings
2018 1616 carlson with five has to do
another berserk
all right so this one will bring him up
the ranks
a five point win
scoring five for first
okay king side is
crunched
knight takes here king back it's made on
the spot that would be a really fast win
oh that's helpful
that was a fast winner
okay
which brings him up to 63rd
this is this should be another berserk
yep all right so nearby another five
another five with a win right here
or we're not even eight eight eight
minutes into this event
big square on d4 for black if you could
get there white needs to take some care
over it that's why we have h3
you don't want the bishop for knight
exchange
most sensitive point d4 it is secure
enough this knight is offset
playing in the center now
i want to be careful about this push
okay he's getting this night off that's
that was probably the best piece
this bishop looks a little stuck
it's a strong move
black's playing this well i i feel
this undermining move h5 this is a
dangerous pawn oh okay well it's gone
though
have a skewer though
rook up and over might be
possible not oh yeah you do have
security with the bishop or the knight
96 can hit
already swiping upon
queens are going to be off
down the exchange
all right but this is excellent now
these guys are going to be passed they
have a check get these guys rolling
looking at the exchange back
it's not
there's this is an interesting
tournament it's more than just uh
winning you gotta win fast
you have to be a berserking machine get
the exchange now
completely winning
i don't see any
any upcoming issues for white the knight
is under control
could take the knight continue to push
maybe that one push this guy push that
guy
okay and he resigns so
in first 26
26 25 hikaru is at 23 another berserk
game carlson's on page four
a question mark opponent this one could
be tricky
we don't know the the question mark for
bullet the blit
the blitz rating is 2583 for this
opponent
carlson in hippo mode
the hippopotamus
that is a sensitive square no doubt
i want to commit that pawn to h4 the
king knight will often look to pivot on
this square so getting out of any
possible pinerones
okay look at that keeping the tension
keeping this diagonal open looking to
damage the king side now maybe nearby
taking the night and taking here
this one has
blown wide open and in the end
we have the two minor pieces versus a
pawn in balance
i'm glad i changed that setting
you can see the material difference
a lot better
taking that maybe taking here knight f4
and mate on g2 is the way i don't see
how you stop that even if the rook is
somehow attacked rook here doesn't
matter knight f4
knight f4 still night check here
with queen takes pawn plenty ways to do
it the queen is in a complete prevent
you go to the corner there's this and
then that
there's a check
there's another check a night move
discovered attack against the rook
incoming
this is a winner
plenty of time in the tank queen
exchange mate threat on f2 made on board
okay
in first little peasant with 30 26
another fast game okay
wow
really
was bishop h3 played
i'm gonna go back
oh my goodness
carlson could have took that bishop for
free
sneaky player
trying to go for a quick minor piece
didn't work out
now these guys are gonna
push through
two connected passers call it three
completely winning 43 seconds plenty of
time carlson in 19th
i think he'll be moving up to page one
shortly
and i believe on page one nakamura okay
he won that game
ali reza's on the first page nakamura's
on the first page nakamura flawless with
27 and with fire carlson still in 32nd
okay still on uh this berserk
streak
we're gonna it's gonna be interesting
once we get a pairing between
carlson and nakamura
is that where the berserking stops
i don't think i think i think each
player is going to stay
stay away
a ways away with their mouse
from that berserk button
you know what
i'm just gonna play a two minute game
here
you know
we'll see
it'll be interesting if one does go
ahead and berserk the other will
will the other player berserk back
or not
all right so is the knight going to dive
in here you probably end up having to
give up the knight for bishop eventually
after knight here king there
oh no maybe maybe jumps here
knight here in captures i don't know if
i like that this is the better bishop
two bishops
and well it's going to be more than that
this pond is officially hunted let's
secure these
this structure first two clean bishops
up
and a pawn
let's see the
technique dr championstein incoming
break e5
knight is not around to stop that break
then he can continue oh there that's a
free knight a resigner and
where does that put him who 30 with fire
in first 34
we're only it only took about 15 minutes
and look at the
all the familiar players okay we have no
berserk game this is a big one
and draken is the opponent
vladimirovich9000
do not want to see this quick g4 g5
assault
it looks awkward this rook right here
but uh trying to defend the pressure on
b2 with b5 you're asking for many a
sacrifices
yeah i i think maybe bishop takes
initially or knight takes on b5
so first things first address this pesky
knight
and then get this knight involved okay
what's going on with this break what's
the plan we have this as an idea okay
super duper duper sharp
uh maybe this one there's knight here or
bishop here no he gets out of the line
of fire right away
now is this one not collapsing this is
very scary for the black king
very scary so this one right here
time to calculate
for sure
taking the rook first pulling this guy
away from f7 that's why this recapture
he wants to stay trained on f7
wow
really
he missed that this was a move
this is crushing for way
no way okay it's threatening mate
holy smokes
uh they still have a minute in the tank
what's the assessment here a knight
versus two pawns in balance
how you stopping these guys this knight
can assist there is pressure here so as
soon as this guy moves you could take
here
oh there's also the offer of a queen
exchange so are the queens gonna come
off
why wasn't i saying that the queens were
in tension i was so fixated on oh you go
here to maybe
address the threat so white wants to
keep the queens on the board
sensing that this king is the more
vulnerable
and now looking at queen h6 oh
uh oh
main two threat
you might have to go here and
hope you can track down these puns
mate in two
oh he missed that maintenance too threat
oh that was a big miss and a big zero
meanwhile look at ali reza
two two and let me go on berserk
let me go on this huge berserk streak
okay another game
big loss
really big loss
he's in the 10 spot
dr championstein okay
light square weaknesses the f5 square is
the big one
some control first over these pawn
advances
international master opponent
okay
black already has this open line
i don't know how i feel about this
position for white it looks a little
scary i don't see
any great pressure against the black
king what's that about okay he's taking
two pawns
to br in order to break up the center
but now the queens are gonna come off
threatening mate threatening a queen
exchange i see the the queen's intention
this time around you could probably take
here with the follow-up this
this isn't a problem d4 this is great
for for black black is up a piece
yeah this is under control
what kind of trouble can he
cause here he has
a three to one majority on the king side
okay it's now a knight versus two pawns
balanced on the clock
what more
cuts out knight c4 doesn't allow this
one to enter
what's the plan
knight here you could do this and even
if there's a counter attack the rook is
hungry
back to back captures
watch out for back ranks flight square
on board slight time edge
or carlson
securing b5
the im is in
the think tank
okay
slow improvements
okay can't take there's pressure here
now there's pressure here as well
it's a really active rook
now the knight can't move as easily so
the pawns start to get marching i'm not
sure the assessment here it's starting
to look like it's maybe closer to even
there are ways to improve here for white
a king on g4 is
it's looking pretty sweet do we capture
here first no we're going to keep that
bishop around
now there's a check
now the pawns continue to march this guy
stays here
securing the king along a rank nearby
there's f6 or excuse me g6 maybe nearby
there could be this one
first okay g6 on board soon two
connected passers
pawns continue to march and you don't
you keep that tension oh and in the end
you're getting the bishop this is
winning just watch out for a tricky
night fork i don't expect that though
plenty of time to think this one through
should be simple technique here for the
doctor
not quite in a position to take the
knight and win the king and pawn ending
get behind the pass pawn king right here
perfect this pawn will be tracked down
next
or do you want to simply march up with
the pawn he's taking like that first and
now the pawn should get rolling watch
out for that trick
okay threatening mate
all right
no resigner
all right he's gonna have to he doesn't
even want the knight
yeah he wants the full queen no
stalemates
all right black resigned
ali reza
had a draw in there oh the draw might
have been against nakamura
all right another game carlson in the 18
spot
20 minutes into this event
okay yeah that loss was a
was a big one here so no berserking in
this game
this player here
i think this may be
i'm not a hundred percent on it
i think this might be jobavah
i think this might be joe bava
probably doesn't have it in the profile
i think joe baba has an account like
this on
another site possibly
yeah i'm not i'm not sure but
um i noticed it a little bit late at the
beginning i wonder if the
initial moves were somewhat of a tell
this is secure
carlson just picked up a huge center
pawn there is some pin here he's freeing
up the knight for starters excellent
pieces these knights are under control
this bishop
all these pieces are under control just
sort this one out
go ahead take my rook i'll take your
knight and then kill your king
oh
so he probably missed that move but
there is still control here i don't
think it's a big deal he does have
plenty of pieces i think black is still
the better side
excellent coordination
let's see
first addressing this pesky light square
bishop wants to
have a knight on f3
knight on h4 watch out for the tricky
knights
rook on d5 should be excellent okay this
one here
bishop on this square
a check first and then another check
here you got the queen and then you
could take here
how's that ending working he's saying
it's better it's winning take here how
dangerous is this this guy's dangerous
though isn't it
king has to go back oh that was a miss
okay and after this move there's that
fancy move if you took this guy this
pawn would bolt
so slick
look at how slick that move was
how tempting it is to want to go here
right oh after you take this i take that
no not so fast
so i'm going to get out of the way and
target this guy now this one is passed
but
yeah
he missed that move the bishop needed to
go here
now you're not stopping this pawn
carlson's going to lose this one
king f6 was a blunder
there's also this four
there's still a four
wow
this one's gone for team black
oh boy
28 seconds
not happening
i don't see
a save happening here
yeah black resigns
wow ali reza taking his first loss
um
nakamura has yet to lose he has 45
carlson in the 53rd spot
okay a double berserk game this is very
good news to see that berserk back
searching for three two losses now
25 minutes into this event
uh let's see
dark square bishops oh i've looked away
at the chat white is uh lights up a
piece here
oh look at how fast man we can have a
quick resigner
should probably resign
go on to the next game
down a piece
and two pawns queens are off if you chop
chop
get the queen back
plays on
knight is pinned
queen is hungry
going on to the very end it looks like
the bishop is closed close
captioning not
in there available
looking like he's flawless with 45 okay
another game another berserk
he's now in the 22nd spot
still no pairing between carlson and
nakamura
black up a pawn
how dangerous is this we can take with
the well i was going to say with the
pawn you could take with the bishop as
well
it seemed more
more like the way to allow the rook to
assist in defending but this is this is
a super defender as well
yeah there's still not enough
the with the queen as the leader this
shouldn't be a
a tough one to defend this night is
stable
and where's that final
piece to attack here it doesn't exist
oh that one
knight takes
and then you can get the queens off if
you want it's going for a check
mate mate is the threat
that wasn't check by the way oh
yeah that wasn't hitting with check okay
anyhow mate on what square was that c2
no berserk in this one
where is carlson now he's in the 11th
spot just a hair out of first place or
first page i should say
bishop hit
c4 is secure
looking to challenge the dark square
bishop
on d5 incoming
you can't take it to be mate
and you don't have to be concerned about
some night move the queen could always
go back we have that and this is the
superior knight you may still want to
dive in now he's looking at that g4
square knight g4 knight h6 possibly
securing the king and against any checks
here problem on a7 preparing to now
double against d6
you can take here and probably double
or just double straight away looking to
exchange okay taking twice king over
this pawn is hit three times defended
twice
let's see the technique
rook and pawn ending more active rook up
a pawn
probably want to keep these guys around
don't exchange all queen side pawns
still with the more active rook
meanwhile this king is
approaching h7 this could be met with
that breaking down the structure
this guy is going to continue to enter
maybe
first h5
and now king here more accessible target
the king all by himself could win the
pawn
rook there here rook there here
two connected passers all this is glued
together
and this should be a resigner right
about now
this guy gonna play on
it's going to play on
these this guy's way too fast though
rook behind
rook check
push
yep
all right black resigns in that position
and the doctor is in eighth with 48.
he's seven back ali reza in first with
55 nakamura second 53 with fire
wow
okay what do we have here no berserk
game
this is exciting who's excited in the
chat
who's not excited in the chat
wow
okay what can we say about this position
what sticks out to me this guy right
here
the c force square
has my attention
in the c3 pawn
healthier structure for black a black
knight would like to be on d6 at some
point
dark square bishop exchange and a knight
here
black could
almost never be worse
all right white making some headway on
the queen side
there goes the c pawn and the a pawn and
a knight
and is the other one going to go here we
might have a knight d7 if bishop here
you may end up taking
oh a blunder
a mouse slipper
we can have a resigner he meant bishop
takes bishop
clearly
okay that was a fast win for the doctor
did i say he
oh
wait a second
i thought carlson lost two games i only
see one zero does that mean he had a
there it is i'm seeing it in the chat
that lexi player
that lexi player
was a cheater
so that's why he moved up in the ranks
so quickly too
his score was adjusted
that means he he has only lost that one
game against in draken
a clown in this tournament i didn't
expect that
wow
okay we have the d5 square
knight on d5
just play against this guy right here on
e7
let's see
it's knight
under control oh cake in space is the
opponent uh they were playing carlsen
was playing against
no no no no no
was he was carlson playing against this
opponent
just the other day
no i think it may have may have been
nakamura
just playing against cake in space
okay anyhow we're really close to this
classic example of superior knight
versus bad bishop if this bit if this
knight could get here bishop says not so
fast
um and it's it's not going to be easy to
kick the bishop off but i think still
even with the rook
ending alone
this should be good there's also a new
square oh there's there's two paths into
d5 now oh absolutely killer
a knight on d5
problem on d6 first bishop here you
could go here kick the rook take the
knight take d6 maybe not so fast though
this this that
okay he won a pawn still has the better
minor piece i don't think that that's
going to change
at some point you could have the
exchange in there but you want to get
something for it there's two connected
passers he's hunting this guy now
probably pr he probably should have
taken some time out for this one but
he's saying uh let's just go
okay black resigned that one and
the doctor is in third look at that
farouza nakamura
okay rob is in there
and then
i don't have the name for rob
for russia nakamura rob
carlson
[Music]
okay another game
and no berserk here so
proceed with caution with that berserk
button
these are all really tense games
let us see
i'm getting word in the chat cake in
space is jordan van forest
okay yeah i don't know like when i'm i'm
not sure like that player
uh lexi i was saying it was joe bava i'm
not certain of that i don't know
it's just uh
um
you know it probably probably wasn't i
don't i don't expect uh
joe bava to be a a cheater at all
so let us see oh what's happening on
this queen side here
oh okay he's going for a queen or a
queen sacrifice because in the end he's
getting this guy tough tough
for team white
no problems for the king
maybe you take here you have to be a
little careful about this guy yeah let's
make sure we reel this one in first
we chop here there this one is secure
can you do something like that
hungry pawn
how's f3 working out
f3 and your way out is what exactly take
here take there and then this what's
wrong with f3
you must be calculating that one
not sure how it works out what is the
imbalanced
queen in three pawns versus two rooks
and a bishop
queen looks nice in the center um
what a cool move huh
they'll just defend the night now i'm
ready to go here and
flush your queen away okay
you could take take the two rooks back
but then you'd get this one
be too my uh you'd be up a minor piece
also this knight is hanging also the
clock
okay i think nearby we may be getting a
pairing carlson versus farouja or
nakamura
we're gonna see he's in the third spot
so first prize again one bitcoin
second is about ten thousand dollars and
third is twenty five hundred
okay
let's see
hunt this pawn next i guess
playing this one on
a check first
so fancy
down 10 seconds yep okay
nakamura in first 71 70 60 for carlson
an hour 24
remaining did nakamura have a loss
no loss is by nakamura
i think just one draw
and that draw might have been against
farouja
okay no berserk here international
master opponent
let us see
d5 is the big square
a lot of security over it
these guys
this guy indirectly c4 oh he's grabbing
this pawn
a6 up for grabs
queen side pressure for black
this one this one is passed i don't know
if you get running with it straight away
first
reroute the bishop the queen a little
a little weird weirdly placed on b5
eliminating some pieces and securing the
queen okay
how to regroup
get this knight maybe here
dives in straight away now he has the e4
square he has a passer as well and maybe
c4 falls
and there is a trick here to get the
piece back on c4 maybe it's defended
indirectly
all right
are there some tricks here knight f6
maybe maybe this and then that and then
this
there's some tricks like that two minor
pieces versus a rook and a really active
queen in the end not quite
bishop vs knight position
centralized queen problem on e5
no
no oh there's two points hit
all right he's going to have an outside
pass pawn
a clean exchange outside pass pawn in
the superior minor piece
a uh a minor piece exchange it's a one
king and pawn ending this guy's more
valuable than the center pawn
you gotta move knight
and this bishop is also stopping okay
you have to go like this
there's a nice
uh well there's some pressure on this
pond you keep this guy right here now
there's possibilities for two
two
outward
uh outside past pawns
he has the time edge he is up upon
and there is no uh there is the
possibility for a wrong color bishop
situation so careful
like if this
and then a night sack for this pun he
can't win so he has to take that into
account
no he wants to win this pawn with the
king instead of maybe exchanging
yeah
and
and now what okay well now you have to
be really delicate
if this knight gets this pawn it's a
draw
wrong color bishop
careful now careful
careful careful careful
okay
if the king gets here it's definitely a
draw
he's running the numbers he's seeing
that it cannot be caught
is that for sure it is for sure black
resigned wow very very delicate position
right there in the ending
nakamura in first 75 second alireza
rob 66
the doctor
currently in fourth with fire 64 big
game against esipenko
no berserks here hour 20 minutes
remaining in this big event
wow really tense
all right what's happening
open d file
security over this square the knight may
look to get into f4 not so fast there's
a pin how do we get out of it
we stay in it for just a moment
all right play on the queen side
secure this if this one this knight
eventually gets here so not so fast with
budging with the b5
where's this knight hopping around to
unclear
where this one's go this guy is going
he's heading for c5 okay i think
eventually you'll have to do this okay
he's taking that and then the queen
could step up
queen could step up he doesn't want to
play with g5
all right oh he just won a pawn oh nice
tactic
getting this oh no it's not so clear
gets this one back okay maybe you push
here
careful about this diagonal if the f
pawn moves
entry bishop here f2 there's a big
problem
it's only like one pawn here
the bishop has them under control this
is the big focal point f7
can add a third attacker shortly maybe
even a timely e3
being able to recapture with check and
then
something good might happen
all right let's see
bishop is a this is the best piece in
the position securing the king
aggressive defensive
what more do you want out of the bishop
problem on this square defends the rook
breaks down this
where are the tricks where are the
tricks
why why is the de why is there delay is
there something other than capturing the
pawn
i guess there is i guess
what would what would happen after the
capture
queen takes king in the corner i'm not
seeing it okay so now we have
black working with that intersection
square
now possibly a queen on
getting the queen to h2
what's the plan here you could take this
pawn maybe track this one down
maybe support the pawn like this but
then you open up yourself to some checks
queen is stopping the checks now also
this pawn is under control
oh there it is
yep look at how that queen weaseled
around h2 nearby
nakamura still undefeated 88 with fire
ali reza second carlson 68 nakamura
up 20 points
huge lead
international master next opponent
wow
queen
under fire knight is in a pin 20 is a
really big lead
really really big lead
what's the plan
you could get a pass pawn this knight
will get to d6 after bishop takes knight
and be a queen side majority doesn't
want that
let us see
oh there goes the a pawn
this is not going well for carlson
down upon
this guy right here
super invasive
now he's in a pin it's out of that
these guys are fast
playing in the center now
probably take with the pawn if there's a
capture on this square otherwise these
knights get a great post all
all pieces all minor pieces get a great
post on e4
rook is now challenged
all right trying to keep it closed
it's not looking good though
white playing really well here
knight c4 nearby knight jumps in no
capture
rook f8
maybe a push whoa he captured
and then queen takes here
oh
and you take the pawn first
he wants this in
definitely wants this and you may want
to put a piece here capture on this
square maybe push
you probably push
okay knight there first
strong defender
okay rook on the second he's gone all in
i don't know if there's enough attacking
force here well maybe
maybe with g4
g4 f3
soon you're gonna be playing down a rook
okay
these guys have to get rolling f3 you
can't
can't afford a queen exchange this and
then here
the king has that f1 square
two queens on the board
not a lot of time
can recap you might as well give up the
no you're not getting two pawns right
away
yeah this is this is not enough
i think carlson's gonna lose this one
yeah he's gonna sacrifice soon
this doesn't work here there the queen
gets to recapture
he's trying to find a way to stir up
some trouble the queen exchange oh okay
this one's gone carlson's down
nakamura lost his first game i can't see
who it's disabled
two losses there
hasn't been updated though
it's not reflecting as a zero just yet
seeing a game
he's online he's not in the game though
uh we're not getting a game yet
not seeing a game
is there a technical issue what's
happening here
you